that came out just a short time ago so
let me start by saying this we don't
take this sort of action without the
most thorough deliberation
and over the course of the last few days
these deliberations have led to a series
of staffing changes
in ukraine
we feel all of these actions were
absolutely necessary and decisions were
made with one thing and one thing in
mind and that is the safety and security
of us citizens and our colleagues on the
ground
now
let me tell you what made this necessary
russia's continued escalation and
seriously threatening military posture
as we have all seen in recent weeks in
recent days we are basing our assessment
on what we are seeing on the ground with
our own eyes
which is a continued and unprovoked
russian
buildup on the border with ukraine
and
no accompanying evidence of
de-escalation
it is a distinct possibility perhaps
more real than ever before
that russia may decide to proceed with
military action
with new russian forces continuing to
arrive at the ukrainian border
and russian forces staged all around
ukraine an invasion as we have said
could begin at any time
should putin decide to order it there
would be widespread human suffering
all the while we are actively working to
try to reach a diplomatic solution and
we remain engaged with the russian
government following president biden's
call with president putin over the
weekend
but since no one has full visibility
into president putin's decision-making
and there hasn't as i said before been
any tangible sign of de-escalation
we have taken the prudent steps of
updating the travel advisory for ukraine
to urge us citizens to leave ukraine
immediately using any available mode of
transportation and now most recently as
you saw just a little bit of go we are
in the process of relocating our
diplomatic staff from kiev to la vie
the staff in la vie including our
charges christina kavin will remain
engaged with ukrainian government
coordinating coordinating and diplomatic
efforts we will continue our close
coordination with ukraine as well as
with our allies and partners
russia
if it sought to do so has failed in its
goal of dividing the united states and
our allies and partners if anything we
are more united as we confront russia's
threats and aggression
we are
intensifying our efforts to deter russia
and to impose costs should moscow decide
to go ahead with military action
whatever happened next happens next
we are resolute in our support for
ukraine's sovereignty for ukraine's
territorial integrity and we will
continue our assistance to the people of
ukraine
it remains unclear to us whether russia
is interested in pursuing diplomatically
pursuing a diplomatic path as opposed to
the use of force we remain committed to
keeping the prospect of de-escalation
through diplomacy alive we will remain
committed to doing that
for as long as we can but russia must
de-escalate and engage in genuine
dialogue and diplomacy
next before i take your questions uh one
additional element i want to take a
moment to explain the executive order
that president biden signed on friday
as we are all acutely aware the people
of afghanistan face enormous challenges
an economic crisis born of decades of
dependence on international aid severe
drought coven 19 endemic corruption
among others
afghan central bank reserves held at the
federal reserve have been inaccessible
for months in part because of the
uncertainty regarding who could
authorize transactions on the account
but also due to pending litigation by 9
11 victims and other victims of
terrorism
victims of terrorism including of the
september 11th terrorist attacks
have brought claims against the taliban
and they are pursuing the central bank's
remain remaining assets in federal court
this administration will continue to
support these victims and their families
recognizing the enduring pain they have
suffered at the hands of terrorists
including those who operated from
afghanistan prior to the september 11th
attacks these victims and their families
should have a full opportunity to set
forth their arguments in court and they
will
we have no idea how long that litigation
will take and in the meantime the
humanitarian and economic situation in
afghanistan continues to deteriorate by
the day
that is why president biden signed the
executive order on friday to preserve
and protect those reserves as part of an
effort to make 3.5 billion dollars
available for the afghan people
fundamentally this eo is aimed at
protecting and preserving funds for the
benefit of the afghan people and we've
taken further steps to set aside 3.5
billion for such uses to try to clarify
that they cannot be attached or seized
the objective is to make these funds
available for the afghan people without
having to wait for the full court
process to conclude
no decision has been made about how
these funds will ultimately ultimately
be used to benefit the afghan people
many of whom are also victims of
terrorism whatever mechanism is
established
it will be designed to minimize the
risks the funds end up in the hands of
the taliban or other sanctioned
individuals or groups
it is ultimately up to the courts to
determine whether the remainder of these
funds should go to victims of terrorism
who hold judgments against the taliban
these funds will continue to be the
subject of ongoing litigation in u.s
courts
by victims of terrorism these victims
and their families as we said should
have a full opportunity to set forth
their arguments
this action marks a significant step
forward in the united states effort to
authorize the transfer of a significant
portion of the funds to meet the needs
of the afghan people
i want to reiterate friday's executive
order was a step towards making a
significant portion 3.5 billion dollars
of these funds accessible to the afghan
people and this action demonstrates that
america's ties to the people of
afghanistan built during two decades of
working side by side are steadfast and
enduring and with that be happy to take
your questions
thanks dad um can i just uh uh on
ukraine um your comments just now and
the decision to close the embassy moved
to
la viv
would seem to suggest that you don't put
a lot of faith in the comments that
foreign minister lavrov made this
morning about
you know
there's still time to for
for diplomacy to work here is that a
fair assessment of your
you understand we have taken note of
this comments what we have not taken
note of
is any indication of the escalation we
have not seen any tangible any real sign
of de-escalation we have been consistent
that we want to pursue the path of
diplomacy we want to resolve uh this
through dialogue through diplomacy
through communication
we hope the russians have a similar
willingness
but we haven't we've also said that in
order for diplomacy and dialogue to
succeed it has to take place in the
context of the escalation and we have
not seen anything resembling
de-escalation there is not that context
yet uh if
foreign minister lavrov's comments are
followed up with concrete tangible signs
of de-escalation we would certainly
welcome that we have not seen that yet
is there
is there any has there been any movement
on another conversation between the
secretary and the foreign minister have
you gotten and also it looks like the
russians are making noise that they've
pretty much finalized their response to
your response
and
so it has
have you been led to believe that
anything on either of those props the
response or another meeting or phone
call
is is coming soon well we've seen uh the
comments from uh the kremlin from moscow
today indicating that uh their response
uh in their words has been finalized
it's been i believe over two weeks now
uh since we uh dispatched our non-paper
to moscow we've yet to see a response uh
that remains accurate uh as of today as
of this moment but we will
of course carefully review um
the
russian written response when we do
receive it uh as you know matt over the
weekend president biden hasn't had an
opportunity to speak to president putin
that call was preceded
by a phone call that secretary blinken
had with foreign minister lavrov while
we were in flight uh during that
during that first call the call between
secretary blinken and foreign minister
lavrov uh foreign minister lavrov
indicated what the russians seem to be
indicating uh now publicly today namely
that is that they are finalizing they
were finalizing at the time uh the
written response that they intended to
transmit to the united states a response
that uh would carry the imprimatur of
president putin
we have yet to receive that but
if the foreign minister did indicate a
willingness on the part of the russian
federation to
engage in dialogue once that response
was received now there was no discussion
uh no no specific discussion as to when
uh that dialogue would take place uh we
don't have anything scheduled at the
moment uh the next step will be the
receipt of the russian response we'll of
course need a bit of time to evaluate it
but as we said we are prepared to engage
in diplomacy we hope to engage uh in
good faith uh dialogue and diplomacy but
in order for it to be good faith of
course uh that will uh require the
russians to respond in kind
in order for this to bear fruit it will
also have to take place in the context
of de-escalation and that is just not
something we've seen today
or anyone else hasn't given you any
indication of what the
content of the of the response might be
no we've seen various public
characterizations of uh the russian uh
view of our non-paper of the non-paper
that was sent over by nato but we'll
have to wait and see what's actually in
the russian response francesca
he has just said that
he's been told
that wednesday this coming wednesday
is potentially the day of russian attack
is that your assumption too is that what
you have shared with your ukrainian
allies
partners well so i'm not going to go
specifically into a great deal of
intelligence what i can say
um let me start by what we're not saying
uh we are not saying that president
putin has made a final decision uh we
have not communicated otherwise
to our partners
we believe that diplomacy continues to
be viable we believe uh that there still
remains a window to resolve this through
dialogue uh and diplomacy what we are
saying and you just heard me say this a
moment ago as i was explaining the
rationale behind the moves in recent
days uh that we have a sufficient level
of concern based on data points that are
as clear to me as they should be to all
of you uh and that's what we're seeing
on the ground it is the massive build up
uh that we have seen continue even uh in
recent days in recent weeks
more than a hundred thousand troops
along ukraine's borders uh uh russian
forces in belarus essentially russia
positioning itself uh to be in a
position should that decision be made
to move quickly and aggressively against
ukraine from
multiple sides that's what undergirds
our concern
we have erred on the side of
transparency with our allies and our
partners of course
that includes ukraine we'll continue to
share with our ukrainian partners
information and intelligence as we are
able um but at this point our assessment
has not changed we believe that a window
remains open to resolve this
diplomatically that is certainly uh the
course we prefer it is of course we will
continue to pursue for as long as we
have a partner on the other side and to
follow up on matt's question on uh any
engagement with lavrov
is is it at this point uh a
de-escalation is it a precondition to
any further in-person engagement with
the prime minister lavrov or not we are
open to dialogue but again in order for
that dialogue to
leads anything in order for it to be
effective uh it would need to take place
in the context of de-escalation right
now the russian military build-up along
ukraine's borders on uh uh along
ukraine's borders and in belarus
has created a very uh tense and
challenging
uh situation it is a very dangerous
situation uh that could escalate uh
whether intentional or not uh with
little or no warning we want to see
de-escalation both for the sake of this
dialogue and diplomacy bearing fruit and
resolving this peacefully uh but also uh
in an effort to uh lower the risk of
conflict uh to lower the risk of uh
[Music]
this turning
uh very bad very quickly that is our
concern right now we have not seen that
de-escalation uh we don't yet know that
uh president putin has made a decision
uh that is why we think diplomacy
continues to be viable uh but we need to
see de-escalation in order for that
diplomacy
when you guys always thought he is
collision but you never defined this
well we have talked about it uh we've
seen this collision on the other side
you know like troops going through
albania
airplanes and so on you know
first of all i would take issue with
that uh what what we have done uh is to
prepare to prepare for either course
that the russian federation may take
again we are prepared and we have
engaged uh in dialogue and diplomacy
we've done that in concert with our
allies and partners but we're also
prepared for the course of defense and
deterrence knowing that president putin
may well decide
uh to order an invasion and now has the
ability to do so uh in short order um
everything that we have done
has been in the vein of defense and
deterrence uh it is uh not nato that is
threatening russia is not ukraine that
is threatening russia nato is a
defensive alliance what we have done uh
is uh reassured uh including through uh
measures that the department of defense
the president has spoken to uh to
reinsure and to reinforce our allies on
nato's eastern flank and to provide
ukraine with uh defensive supplies that
ukraine would need to defend itself uh
should russia make the decision uh to
move forward with an unprovoked uh
attack against ukraine that is not in
the vein of aggression that is quite the
opposite that is in the vein of defense
and deterrence in terms of
the steps russia would need to take i'm
not here to define uh what russia needs
to do
there are a range of steps that the
russian federation could take that would
signal de-escalation there are there are
more than a hundred thousand forces a
raid along ukraine's borders there are
thousands of forces in belarus
we've heard um
bellicose rhetoric emanate from elements
of the russian federation all of those
things could change this buildup has
taken place in the course of a couple
months uh in the course of uh hours or
days we could
see tangible signs of de-escalation
if russia makes the political decision
to do so barbara
recently suggested very vaguely that
perhaps the notion of nato membership
might not be achievable he said it is
for us like a dream and of course you
had the comments from the um ukrainian
ambassador to the uk in which he
suggested it might
be up for some kind of negotiation
although that's been walked back and
they said it's part of the constitution
and so on but there is discussion
perhaps on how to respond to this
particular crisis and whether nato
membership
might be part of that what are the
americans saying to ukraine about that
is that something that you are
encouraging is that something that you
are
advising on
some kind of formula
that that might be a place where there
could be a diplomatic um
solution because it seems unlikely
there'll be some kind of solution
without involving ukraine's status
ukraine's aspirations are not a matter
for us to decide ukraine's aspirations
are not a matter for any other country
to decide we've been very clear about
this and this is at the core of what
we've been saying in terms of that
diplomacy there are some areas where
through
the course of good faith discussions and
negotiations we think
we could improve
our own address some of our own security
concerns the security concerns of the
transatlantic community that is to say
the shared concerns of the united states
of our european allies and partners and
also address the stated concerns of the
russian federation and we've delineated
a number of those uh a number of those
are now available online uh to
subscribers of el pais to see for
themselves uh so i need not go into them
now at the same time
we've been consistent all along there
are some things that are non-negotiable
they have raised with you
i'm not going to go into
discussions with the with our ukrainian
partners but our message to them both
public and private uh has been that no
country
no other country should be in a position
uh to dictate the aspirations of any
other country whether that is ukraine or
any other country around the world
this is we've made the point repeatedly
uh
tensions that moscow have
has uh provoked needlessly uh tensions
that moscow has precipitated uh for no
reason uh but in many ways what we are
seeing here is bigger than
uh the
tensions between russia and ukraine the
tensions between
russia
and the international community and that
is because what russia is threatening
uh itself is an affront to the
rules-based order that has undergirded
70-plus years of unprecedented levels of
stability of security of prosperity uh
if moscow purports to dictate
international borders if moscow purports
to dictate the foreign policy decisions
that moscow reports to dictate uh the
alliances and partnerships of any other
country uh that would be an assault uh
on that order it had implications
certainly for ukraine but it had
implications far beyond ukraine and i
think that is why you see not only the
united states but also the united states
and our partners and allies uh speak up
firmly speak up with one voice to make
clear uh that
uh
we would not stand for it uh and that
there would be profound profound
consequences
for moscow should it choose to move
forward with that aggression missy
on the embassy so the can you just
confirm that the marine guards are also
gone and that there's nobody left and
who will be responsible for presumably
the ukrainian government but what are
the arrangements around safeguarding the
facility and then just to clarify on the
potential for further diplomacy with the
russians
is it your understanding um
or what is your understanding regarding
whether or not they have agreed
firmly to
more nato russia council talks or the
you know the um
secure the bilateral talks or the osce
talks or have they just sort of
indicated general openness to it and
what's what's your understanding based
on the recent discussions so on your
first question regarding our status in
ukraine we are in the process of moving
our operations from keefe
to levi the charges is already in uh
levive the vast majority of our team is
in uh leve
we
are grateful to
the ukrainian national guard
and
ukrainian national guard police i should
say who will guard
our embassy uh in kiev uh it is
certainly our intention to return to
that embassy in kiev just as soon as it
is uh safe for us uh to do so when it
comes to
the dialogue uh
as i've said before the russians have
indicated a willingness at least stated
in a willingness uh to continue to
engage uh in dialogue and diplomacy uh
we certainly hope that is the case we
certainly hope they will do so uh in
good faith uh in the context
of de-escalation we have also been very
clear with the russians
that this cannot be exclusively a
bilateral matter because it is not a
bilateral matter
this is an issue that involves
of course uh ukraine in the first
instance uh nato europe uh and that is
why uh we have continued to uh insist uh
that uh even if and we hope there is uh
additional bilateral contact between the
united states and the russian federation
that that would be accompanied
by additional engagement at the
nato-russia council through the osce
what we know at the very least is that
any additional bilateral engagement
between the united states and the
russian federation which again we hope
uh takes place and takes place in the
context of de-escalation would continue
to be we would continue to closely
coordinate
that engagement with our ukrainian
partners with our european allies as
well a number of countries
are now engaging on a bilateral basis
with the russian federation and we think
that's a good thing we think that is a
good thing because
these countries including the french
including the germans
they have done so in close and extensive
coordination with the united states as
you know president biden has had now a
couple opportunities to speak to
president macron
chancellor schultz was just in
washington i believe it was last week
where he met with uh president biden
secretary blink and was also in that
meeting so we've been in close regular
extensive consultation uh with our
allies and partners but as for the next
steps uh first will uh it's our
impression that we'll be in receipt of
uh the russian response and we'll have
to take it from there
of any specific
um nrc or ssd or osce meeting will would
come if it comes after you guys get the
response well i can't speak for nato i
can't speak for the osce what i can say
at this point uh is that there is not uh
another engagement on the books uh right
now but again we hope there is one uh
and we hope there is one that uh gives
way uh to de-escalation and to the
diminution of tensions yes tracy thank
you
question um can you say for the record
why
levied is really that much safer for
american diplomats than kiev
given the multi-pronged overwhelming uh
invasion that so many of you are are
forecasting is it a way to sort of
pretend you still have a presence in the
country no it's it's a matter of
geography uh and levi's location of
course uh affords it a degree of uh
protection that other uh places in
ukraine may not have uh the buildup of
forces on
ukraine's eastern uh
borders uh the buildup of forces along
its northern border with belarus uh of
course that has implications for large
swaths of ukraine including keith uh we
have made the determination to
uh
to move our operations uh to la viv um
out of consideration for the safety and
security of our personnel on the ground
and when you say the vast majority of
our team is there now and libby do you
mean the vast majority of the original
fool and this year you mean the vast
majority of the core team well we've
been drawing down our embassy presence
for some time uh as you know we ordered
uh we went to order departure for
dependents we went to authorized
departure
for some of our staff
now a number of days ago
with the order departure we have drawn
down further some of those
members of our team
have returned to the united states
others are going to other locations uh
inside of europe now we have a core
team that remains in ukraine
we are in the process of moving that
remaining core team from keeve to lavish
i know you won't say numbers but like
does that core team what ten percent of
the original
i i i'm just not in a position to get
into numbers
yes
ed thank you mark stone from sky news a
couple of points can i just get
clarification on um there have been
reports that
uh documents and and computers in the
embassy in kiev um are being destroyed
uh is that correct
um can i also ask
about um reports that
you've seen artillery pieces and and
troops on the russian side being moved
into an attack position as it's been
described do you recognize that um and
then a more broad point if i can um the
the zelinski the president zilinski
comments about a wednesday attack in the
last few moments his spokesperson said
he was being sarcastic
and
in his statement can you explain that
the clear disconnect between
what the ukrainian government is saying
about the threat
and what the west is saying about the
threat because i think the public is a
bit confused globally
uh understood remind me of your first
question again the first question was
just uh details on uh on whether stuff
is being destroyed in the embassy uh so
as you know uh we've been planning for
uh this contingency as we do for a range
of contingencies uh for some time now
and there are a standard set of
procedures uh that will be set into
motion uh when we do begin an embassy
drawdown and certainly
when we relocate our operations from one
site to another i can't get into the
full set of those operations but those
operations
were set in motion uh as appropriate uh
what i can say is that we had been
planning for this uh there was a great
deal of meticulous uh planning that went
into this and as as a testament to that
for example we did not have to destroy
any valid passports
we have undertaken prudent precautions
when it comes to
sensitive documents sensitive equipment
but just can't offer a whole lot of
detail there your question on various
reports of artillery moving into attack
positions uh what i can say is that we
have uh grown uh increasingly concerned
by what we have seen on the part of the
russian federation uh in recent weeks
and week in recent days uh some of these
reports are uh again very public uh
clear as day uh in terms of additional
forces uh heading towards arriving at uh
the border with ukraine additional
forces going into belarus um not in a
position to detail the uh full
uh rationale for our concern but our
concern uh has only increased we have
not seen uh indications of de-escalation
uh that we've called for that we think
are necessary uh if diplomacy uh is to
is to uh bear fruit uh when it comes to
the uh what what you're hearing from uh
president zielinski from our ukrainian
partners
look we are coordinating extremely
closely
with them uh
the
secretary had an opportunity to speak to
foreign minister kuleba this morning
president biden spoke to president
zielinski yesterday uh the secretary uh
just a couple days ago had another
conversation with foreign minister uh
cooleva we will continue that level of
coordination we'll continue that level
of uh information sharing across every
dimension we have aired uh on the side
of transparency uh with our ukrainian
partners we think that is important
precisely because uh they are our
partners they are the ones that are
facing uh a potentially eminent threat
from the russian federation
and so that's why we've continued to uh
engage with them
as concerned about the threat as you are
the the ukrainian ambassador to
washington has made very clear
statements uh she has indicated that uh
they are uh seeing much of the same
information we are um and that is for a
simple reason because we are uh sharing
robust amounts of uh information uh
information with them so it's not the
threat i mean the intent
president putin's intent they don't seem
convinced that he has the intent the
threat is obvious it's on the border
well as we've said um we also do not
know that president putin has made the
decision uh what undergirds our concern
is precisely the threat that you were
speaking to that our ukrainian partners
have spoken to that is uh visible to
everyone here uh there's a good reason
uh why we are taking the prudent
precautions uh that we've taken these
are the american citizens in ukraine who
we've urged
for some time now to leave immediately
using commercially available options to
take overland routes and in fact even in
recent hours we provided additional
guidance to american citizens on the
ground in ukraine telling them
specifically which border crossings they
should use facilitating uh their access
uh through engagement with our polish
allies that will help them uh across the
polish border on an expedited basis uh
it is precisely why we've taken the
steps we announced today uh relocating
our embassy operations from kiev to leve
uh it's precisely why uh we are taking
uh these prudent steps in the vein of
defense and deterrence uh that that we
have the threat is very real i don't
think anyone uh is arguing about uh the
severity of the threat uh that uh the
russian federation is currently posting
simon thank you
a little bit more about the decision to
move the embassy um how to move embassy
operations you know is that something
that um you discussed with the ukrainian
government uh before you did it and you
know what was their response to you
doing that because you know you're
saying that
you're going to continue to engage with
the ukrainian government but you're
going to be in a different city to
where the ukrainian government is right
so how how does that work do you expect
ukrainian officials to shuttle back and
forth from kiev to levi or is the charge
going to come to kiev
it seems like you're saying that kiev is
not
safe for americans to be there right now
so you know how how can
your you know level of engagement remain
the same with the ukrainians and and
this not be a message to them that
you know we're no longer
stuck with you in short
well let me start by saying uh precisely
what the relocation of our operations
doesn't signal uh it does not signal any
diminution on our part uh for uh the
territorial integrity for the
sovereignty for the independence of
ukraine uh quite the contrary there are
a number of functions uh that are going
to remain we are going to continue to be
in a position to provide defensive
security assistance uh to our ukrainian
partners that will absolutely continue
uh our charges i will um
currently is in uh leve she will remain
in regular constant contact uh with our
ukrainian partners of course much of
that contact takes place from our
team on the ground and keeve but as you
saw just again this morning secretary
blinken is in frequent contact uh with
foreign minister kulepa uh and i suspect
uh that will continue as well um what
this does signal is one thing and one
thing only uh and that is precise that
is uh
the priority we attach to the safety the
security uh of american citizens uh whom
we've put now um
uh urged to leave the country uh
immediately and also to our colleagues
who are on the ground to their uh safety
and security only the united states
government uh has
that priority when it comes to the
safety and security of american citizens
including our colleagues
no other country no other entity uh can
be in a position to make a judgment
about what is in the best security
interests
of our colleagues on the ground and it
is our considered judgment uh that it is
now prudent uh for our colleagues to
relocate from keith to
precisely because of the threat
the specific threat to u.s diplomats
because you know like that would be
presumably a um
a breach of uh i guess the geneva
convention that you know ukrainians are
responsible for protecting diplomats in
the country you're kind of implying that
if the russians do come into kiev they
can't be trusted to
uh
respect diplomats you know even in the
second world war diplomats stayed in
berlin for example
um you know is there a specific reason
you have to believe that those diplomats
would face harm
we're not here and this move does not
indicate there's any specific threat to
american personnel on the ground in
ukraine but what we do know uh is uh
given the capabilities that the russians
are poised to deploy should president
putin make that decision uh that
incursion into ukraine uh could entail
um massive uh violence massive
destruction uh and the loss of life uh
would not discriminate uh between
americans ukrainians uh others and so it
is uh in our considered judgment a
prudent step for uh our team on the
ground to to relocate from keeve to
laveed we've talked about the geographic
reasons uh while aviv is a prudent step
uh at this point um but again this is
not out of concern that uh our diplomats
would be any more uh under threat than
anyone else
uh yes russell yeah i have a couple of
questions one chancellor schultz is on
his way to moscow
has the administration contacted him
gotten us a sense of what's really
happening in cave right now and is the
u.s giving him a message to give to
president putin and then my other
question is and it falls on simon's
point what is the us's commitment to
ensuring that the zelinski government or
any democratically elected government in
ukraine remains intact and does not
become a proxy state for moscow
when it comes to our german allies as i
alluded to already chancellor schultz uh
was only recently uh at the white house
he had an opportunity to sit down with
president biden secretary blinken was in
attendance uh for that meeting as well
to discuss our joint and shared approach
uh to the uh
crisis that moscow has needlessly uh
provoked and it is a joint approach you
heard that from chancellor schultz when
he was standing next to president biden
at the white house you heard that from
chancellor schultz even in recent hours
uh in terms of his comments uh about the
strong
unified response that would befall
moscow wore it to pursue the path of
aggression so we are in regular contact
uh with our german allies um our embassy
in berlin but also here from uh the
state department i uh fully expect that
uh high level engagements uh will take
place uh in the coming days with our uh
german allies as i said before there are
a number of countries
the germans the french included
that have uh engaged at senior levels
with the russian federation we have all
been doing this uh with
that um
that core
precept in mind nothing about without
when it comes to the united states and
the close coordination the close
consultations uh that uh
that we have engaged in those have been
reciprocated uh from our allies who
themselves uh have engaged with the
russian federation
look i don't want to get into a
hypothetical when it comes to what may
happen next our goal is to deter our
goal is to do everything we can to
prevent a conflict uh from breaking out
that is why uh we continue to uh leave
open uh the possibility for diplomacy
not only to leave that open but to very
clearly indicate and know in certain
terms that it's our preference we are
ready and willing to continue
discussions uh in close concert concert
in consultation with our
allies and partners
regarding means to de-escalate this um
what is required for that to bear fruit
however is de-escalation uh and there is
only one side that has escalated there
is only one side that is in a position
uh to de-escalate uh and that is the
russian federation that is yet what we
see
very clear
to the russians you know one of the
things that they have looked at is
what they consider an encroaching
opposite political philosophy on their
borders can you categorically say that
the us will not stand for a change of
government in ukraine in order to end
this crisis there is a democratically
elected government uh in place in kiev
uh it is up to the ukrainian people uh
in uh through the course of democratic
elections uh to choose their leaders it
is not up to any other country to do so
sure
i have a couple questions on the
palestinian issue
we seem to be where we were a year ago
with the chef de raj situation and there
has been an increased aggression by the
settlers there's a guy who
placed an office there
i know that you have spoken against this
before you've spoken against the
expulsion of palestinians but why can't
you make it very clear in no uncertain
terms that we will not stand for this
that this must end
satan we've uh engaged on this publicly
we've also engaged on this privately uh
what we have said uh publicly uh is that
um well first let me say that we're
following very closely uh developments
in shikhara both
on the ground and here from washington
uh and we're deeply concerned by the
events of this past weekend um
we've said this many times before
we believe it is critical for all
parties to refrain from unilateral steps
uh that have the potential to exacerbate
tensions uh and to move us further away
from efforts to advance negotiated to
state solution uh we have and we are
strongly urging all parties uh against
inciting violence and we are urging calm
on the part of all parties but you know
it's the israelis that are really taking
the steps they are your closest allies
i'm sure you will a great deal of
influence and pressure on them what
can't you say this this shifty rock
situation must end you cannot
expel people from there beside we
you alluded to this uh yourself we have
made very clear uh our position on those
families uh who call shakespeare home uh
in many cases over the course of uh
generations um again our uh priority is
to see to it uh that all parties uh
refrain from steps that have the
potential to exacerbate tensions or to
move us farther away uh from the in
state that uh we hope to see and that's
the two stages why are they really not
hitting your call for them
to refrain from taking in lateral steps
right
beside i'm not here to speak for the
israeli government i'm here to
speak to
our policy and to our approach and our
approach is to do everything we can
to
keep tensions at bay to urge calm uh to
work with the parties uh to do just that
yes
the update we've seen very
positive comments on the progress made
in vienna by
joseph burrell by
the russian
delegate there uh do you share that
positive comments
you guys have said before the the the
this round of talks resumed last week we
will see very very quickly if there is a
political will decision to make a deal
have you seen that
so francesco as you know the special
envoyance team remain on the ground in
vienna i have to say that
we are going to be a bit more
circumspect in terms of uh
progress uh that we may be seeing on the
ground in vienna precisely because
we are in the final stages of what is by
any measure a complex negotiation with
key stakeholders the fact is that this
is the final decisive period
during which we'll be in a position to
determine whether a mutual return to
compliance with the jcpoa
remains a possibility
our european partners as well as china
and russia
all of us urgently seek
to achieve an understanding
but
time is almost out
time is uh very quickly ticking away
we've been very clear that at the
current rate of iran's nuclear
advances we have little time left and
that's precisely because uh at a certain
point very soon those nuclear advances
uh will obviate the advantages that the
jcpoa
as it was finalized in 2015 and
implemented in 2016 uh initially uh
conveyed so uh the teams are continuing
to meet uh for our part those
discussions continue to be incorrect uh
with the iranian delegation but uh we
know that uh we're speaking with one
voice uh together with our p5 plus one
plus one partners all of them recognize
uh the importance of uh concluding uh in
whatever form that takes uh these talks
in in uh in short order meaning this
week next week
uh yemen yeah
uh there's been a deployment of
22 into the emirates does that mean that
you guys are you know citing with the
arab coalition the salinity coalition in
this foreign you know
so the deployment that you're referring
to
of f-22 raptors uh this is a uh this
deployment is defensive in nature uh it
is part of a broad
demonstration of u.s support after a
series of terrorist attacks
that our partners in the emirates as
well as in saudi arabia have endured
from yemen
the department of defense in the same
vein has sent a navy guided missile
destroyer the uss cole to partner with
the uae navy and they'll continue to
provide early warning intelligence and
they'll collaborate on air defense
so collectively i think you will see
that we are committed to helping our
emirati partners defend themselves uh
against the aggression that we've seen
emanate from yemen we stand with the uae
uh as a strategic partner that's the
signal we're sending but such a step is
not likely to shorten the war i'm sorry
again will such as that
be in any way
like an element towards shortening the
war our our goal is to bring this
conflict to an end uh our goal is to
work with uh the parties uh to work with
u.n special envoy to work with our saudi
partners with our emirati partners uh
with the republic of human government
and others uh to bring this conflict uh
to an end for a couple reasons uh first
and foremost uh conditions inside yemen
the humanitarian emergency that by most
accounts is the worst humanitarian
catastrophe on the face of the earth
more than 16 million minis
who are suffering from some level of
food
insecurity but also uh the violence that
yemenis themselves uh are enduring now
of course we see that violence spilling
over uh into neighboring countries
precisely because uh the houthis have
undertaken uh these uh terrorist attacks
it is our goal uh with these steps uh
the steps he referred to the deployment
of these additional defensive elements
uh to help our partners uh defend
themselves uh but that in no way
replaces our emphasis on the diplomacy
because we know only through a
diplomatic end to this conflict will we
be able to address uh humanitarian
concerns in yemen the security concerns
inside yemen but also uh the threat that
our partners face emanating from yemen
i am not responsible for the deployments
of
such assets
anything else
okay
thank you
you